he's a Mitchell true Biscay joining us
on behalf of gone rogue it's a product
combining the crunchiness of a potato
chip with the protein rich benefits of
jerky and the Chicago Bears quarterback
joins us now
how are you Mitch I'm doing okay no
complaints when's the last time you
threw a football yesterday now Oh TA
what about Mike and uh let's say
backyard stuff do you have a backyard
yeah I got a backyard okay do you who do
you throw to either my roommate or I
usually will just throw the facility
with whoever I can find a catch for me I
mean we have certain offseason rows I
can't throw to my teammates within
certain hours but any time I could pick
up the football and throw it I
definitely do and so I try I got plenty
of gloves at the house for my roommate
to wear she's not okay if somebody a
teammate comes over let's say you're
having a barbecue you can't throw a
football to that teammate if in certain
designated times like casual talk you
can you can you can't it
the rules are crazy you can't play catch
at the facility with your teammates
throughout certain hours so you get like
four hours a day I think and the field
work is divided up into that but if I
had the guys over to my house and wanted
to play catch in the backyard or run
plays I you could definitely do that
okay yeah but you could do it like just
do a barbecue and out pattern party yeah
we could you could do that we could play
catch buddy got barbecues we go play
golf we could we could do a lot of
things growing up in Ohio were you
Browns fan I was a little bit I was more
a high school football where I'm from
Mentor Ohio was huge so I was a big
mentor Cardinal fan I was a ball boy for
that team so I didn't really watched a
lot of college or NFL but obviously
being from that area you do support the
Browns but I was really bought into the
high school
best high school player your school was
who alright
you were you were mr. Ohio weren't you I
was I was but the guy I really lucked up
see was Bart and he was mister Ohio
before me he was really the player I
idolized and looked up to growing up and
kinda cloud based and I gave him after I
was a ball boy when he was starting
quarterback and he was our first mister
Ohio and then I was lucky enough to win
as well
did you upgrade from the 1997 Toyota
Camry I did I did I'm with oh how do you
now okay alright it's not bad I can see
how d-did you trade in the Camry I did
not I passed it down it's on the family
what advice would you give these young
quarterbacks that just got drafted
what's the one piece of advice it since
you're now a veteran if you had a chance
to talk to Kyler Murray today on or off
the field as far as advice what would
you say you gotta block out the outside
noise social media the media and all the
naysayers easier said than done because
everything that's going on with social
media these days so just block
everything out on the outside and as
everyone knows work hard grind do all
those things but I think the most
important thing for these guys come in
and just come in humble to your team you
got a earn the respect of your teammates
and coaches and it's gonna be a process
gonna be one day at a time
showing them through your play your work
ethic who you are as a person working
very hard and earning their respect and
showing them who you are as a player so
and then also realizing that there's
going to be adversity it's not going to
be easier to play there's going to be
ups and downs and if you just go in with
that mindset that no matter what comes
your way you're going to be able to
overcome it and stay true to who you are
then I think it'll all work out but
it'll definitely be a process early on
what was your welcome to the NFL moment
my welcome to the NFL moment was
probably when I realized I had to get
off social media because all the people
either tweet me there wasn't a good
player I wear I think deserve to be in
the position that I was in and that's
when I was like I'm just gonna get off
this and handle my business on the
football field because I'm very blessed
and fortunate to be in the position that
I am and you you don't need negative
people in your life coming that you
didn't work for this or you didn't
deserve something like that well I know
that I put the work in and I'm very
blessed unfortunately being in position
I am but early early on you're just
gonna have a lot of people gotten you so
for me the welcoming moment that there's
a lot of people who were either jobs
through position or think you don't
deserve it
and you just you just gotta block that
out what about your welcome to the NFL
moment on the field on the field
definitely just getting sacked or
tackled by NFL teal and then Mike who's
you have one that stands out here take
him taking their first big hit I got hit
by Kyle Williams at Buffalo last year
I'm still seeing this family right he
you put it on there right into my chest
and landed right on top man I'm still
feeling that but uh definitely that or
for me it's just playing that soldiers
feel that's still welcome to the NFL
moment being able to walk in that locker
and have all the history of our building
playing at Soldier Field and play in
front of our home crowd that really
never gets old for me it's been amazing
and we're definitely excited headed into
year three for me to get back to Soldier
Field and make this it is Chicago club
he's a Mitchell true Biscay nicknamed
mr. Biskit I still love that nickname do
you like that nickname yeah first there
was the whole Mitch Mitchell dilemma now
it's mr. Biskit money Mitch prettyboy
assassin I have true so they come about
my last and true or they split it up
it'll be true or they just call me
Biscay and
it's just really piling on so I just
kind of embraced them all and I like
true I think true is really good I true
yeah yeah fan favorite somewhat dazzling
team who got you the Mike Ditka sweater
last year my equipment manager Tony
Medellin I told him I had this idea that
I want to do it pay tribute to coach
Ditka and he hooked it up the sweater
vest was the only missing piece I had
everything else I already had I had the
tie of the shirt okay obviously the
sweater vest puts it all together and
then the sunglasses can't forget to
sunglasses no I'd like to liked it a lot
let me see how you're doing since Peyton
Manning's retired you know we're looking
for the next quarterback pitchman and
you're joining us on behalf of gone
rogue here is your moment here's Mitch
true biscay true mr. Biskit Biscay
all right sell your product here all
right here we are I'm very excited to be
with it gone rogue high-protein snack
it's it sounds like it's too good to be
true but it's amazing answers smack
there it's basically has the crunchiness
of a of a chip but it's a very healthy
substitute 17 grams of protein per bag
this is a fact and it's been amazing for
me sausage and before or after workout
it's just a healthy snack that you can
have in between meals and you don't feel
bad about it because it's it's super
healthy for you so it's actually a lean
chicken that's been smoked and then
sliced and baked and that's what makes
it crunchy and they got all these
amazing flavors mine's barbeque so it's
just like chips except it's it's healthy
smoked chicken and it sounds like it's
too good to be true that's not so make
sure you order someone am it's a gone
rogue snacks dot-com have you had your
fanboy moment where you say something
stupid to like a Idol think you know if
you meet somebody drew brees or Aaron
Rodgers Brady anybody you have those
moments yet no I haven't I haven't I
usually I wouldn't say anything dumb it
would probably I wouldn't
anything at all and I'd be awkward so I
so I don't know if I've had that moment
yet but to stay away from those I
usually just don't do it but okay after
the Packers game when you guys open up
with the Packers you wouldn't say
something Aaron Rodgers no I just
good game go go the other way that's it
you wouldn't you wouldn't exchange
jerseys no I don't I would only ask like
friends or people that I have a good
relationship with for jerseys like
people that I like know pretty well by
guys like guys who I've played with or
have gotten and know throughout my time
in the league but I would never ask like
someone I look up to or I've watched for
a long time for a Jersey I must say
unless I wanted to what jerseys do you
have I have Matt Collins from the Eagles
Ryan Switzer with the Steelers but I
know there's old Dallas your game I have
Garrett Bowles from Denver I had TJ
Logan from Arizona
I had dak Prescott from Dallas by George
kiddo from San Fran and I have MJ
Stewart from Tampa Bay and I had Joan
from Seattle so a lot of my college
teammates and couple other friends goes
well that's cool it's great to talk to
you and good luck being a spokesperson
more importantly Congrats on the season
good luck with this upcoming season
appreciate so much that me on and I
heard about everything that's going on
with you and just want to say that I
wish you all the best and I'm praying
for you then we're both warriors Mitch I
mean I'm just taking it one snap at a
time
Thank You bud that's a mr. Biskit for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app